com isso vai jantar widerson com fome na
mãe que eu já não sou eu quem vai ter
que ajustar nossa comida f dá pra tirar
foto batalha estágio na holanda
meu filho está na hora de acordar e ver
que foi acordado e fiz aquela amiga que
você gostar aqui na porta não fechei que
em casa e fiz a minha está aqui na minha
perna visão louca quatro desafios que
existe rede tube city ims vídeo mãe pelo
amor de deus não é esse o livro com esse
negócio
meu filho você tem que se alimentar num
ficheiro em seu computador nã o hã eu já
comi de cinzas mas pelo amor de deus e
escandalosa que contactam meu filho
quebrou a perna no fim cada cosa ai mãe
possa fazer história já é o curto você
tentava resgatar o amor de deus
a nosso ver não na redução e faz
escândalo qualquer conta do fogo sabe
contar outro vou sair daqui pra tá muito
confortado tá frio aqui o tatá e ritinha
o que comeu e diretor que a galera no
facebook e interagir aqui tudo até
simulando da interação
obrigado a derrubar a regra do jogo
abriu a boca do carregador
o carregador carreira pega o carro é
gato e um carregador no facebook
como eu vou viver muito do jogador
ae andou fazendo um carregador não tem
creche e da tia a portaria no carregador
banana o tape tó